Speaker 1: . It's a great pleasure today to
be speaking with Geoffrey West, who's a theoretical
physicist and professor at the Santa Fe Institute.
One of his great books, which I recently read,
is Scale the universal laws of growth, innovation,
sustainability and the pace of life in organisms,
cities, economies and companies.
Professor West, it's so great having you on.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, thank you for inviting
me.
Pleasure to be on.
Speaker 1: So I want to start with something
very basic just to kind of get the audience
acquainted with the subject matter of the
book.
When we talk about scale in life, we can apply
this to the human body.
We can apply this across species, we can look
at businesses, cities, et cetera, as you do.
How did you first come into being interested
in this concept of scale in life?
Speaker 3: Well, I think really, it originated
from a theoretical physicist in terms of my
training or my career dealing with fundamental
questions in physics, you know, quarks and
gluons, and string theory and evolution of
the universe, et cetera.
You know, those big questions.
But in that a major theme in that and in fact,
across physics and all engineering and technology
is the question of scale.
How do you scale up?
What happens if you scale up a body, if you
scale up a building, if you scale up the universe,
you know what?
You know, some of these might be hypothetical
questions, but some of them are, you know,
very seriously practical questions that we
have to face in society.
So so I got interested from a fundamental
physics, but realizing that that was sort
of the thing that later in my career that
this had implications, just as you said, across
the entire spectrum of the world around us.
Speaker 1: In the book, you give examples
of aspects of life that scale linearly, sub
linearly or super linearly, and this gives
rise to certain efficiencies and inefficiencies
that we can identify a number we couldn't
possibly talk about every interesting anecdote
that you include in the book.
But again, to give the audience some idea
of what we're talking about, could you give
us one example of each of these three phenomena
in life that can be observed?
Speaker 3: Sure, yes.
So the simplest is linear.
Linear simply means if I doubled the size
of the system, I get something twice as big
than somebody.
So, for example, if you doubled the size of
a city, not surprisingly, you sort of get
twice as many dwellings.
Let's call it that way, you know, twice as
many houses because each person, so to speak,
needs a place to live.
So that's linear.
So that's not surprising.
But the sublineage are what we call sub linear
is when if you double the size, you don't
get twice as much, but you get less than twice
as much.
So, for example, to take a different system
at mammals, we're a mammal and we go from
a shroom to a mouse to master elephants of
blue whales.
And what is amazing is if you look at any
quantity that describes the many physiological
variable, like the number of heartbeats, the
length of the aorta, how long they live.
These scale in a very regular systematic way.
And one of the most fundamental quantities
is metabolic rate, how much food you need
each day to stay alive.
And if you double the size of an organism
or you look to one was twice the size of another,
you might have naively expected, well, you
need twice as much food.
You have twice as many cells.
No, right?
Roughly speaking, three quarters as much you
say 25 percent with the same with.
That's called sublineage scaling and is a
manifestation of a systematic economy of scale.
Speaker 1: So before you give us an example
of super linear?
Yeah, to think about that example, you could
in a sense have a an individual that weighs
twice as much as another.
They don't need twice the food, they only
need 75 percent more.
It's more efficient on a per pound basis.
In that sense, yes.
Speaker 3: So what I would like to talk about
here is less about those within species than
across species.
All right.
Discuss scaling.
We can also discuss scaling within.
It's slightly different.
Sure.
But if you just look at just across species
or across different mammals, then there's
this saving.
So put slightly differently.
Each cell in your body, if you double the
size, actually requires less energy, the bigger
you are.
And by the way, that feeds into why it is
that bigger animals live much longer than
smaller ones because they're using less energy
to support the same gram of tissue or the.
Same cell.
So it's a systematic economy of scale, and
by the way, we see that in our cities.
It's the same thing in terms of our infrastructure.
You double the size of a city.
I said you need twice as many houses, but
you only need about 85 percent as many roads
or 85 percent as much electrical lines.
So it's quite similar to biology, except the
saving is sort of 50 per cent with each doubling
rather than 25 percent.
But it's again an economy of scale sublineage
scaling.
Speaker 1: Now, an example of of super linear
Speaker 3: Yes, so Superman is scaling is
quite fascinating because it really does not
occur in the natural biosphere.
It's almost almost sublineage scaling, and
the biosphere is incredibly efficient.
It's this economy of scale permeates.
On the other hand, but social systems, social
economic systems have the opposite behavior,
and that comes about because socioeconomic
systems are driven by social networks interaction
between people like you and I are doing.
And we build on each other in terms of the
conversation.
And that means the bigger you are, instead
of having the less per capita, so to speak,
you have the born per capita.
So the example would be, for example, if you
asked how many patents, how many ideas are
created in a city and look at it as a function
of the size of a city.
So again, totally naively, if you doubled
the size of the city, that means you have
twice as many people where you might get twice
as many patents.
No, you actually get another 50 percent added
every time you double.
So the bigger the city, the more ideas are
created.
And that's because they're more social interactions
and so on, and the more and more socioeconomic
actually, the higher the wages per capita
and so on and so forth.
Speaker 1: So we would expect we would expect
that in a one million person city, there would
be more patents than in the sum total of 10
100000 person cities.
Speaker 3: Exactly.
That's a very nice way of saying it in a way
we often say it is like that.
I think that's it's a very powerful way of
saying you gain tremendously by bringing people
together rather than giving them up into groups
subgroups which act autonomously.
And of course, you gain something back because
I mean, that's not going to be quality of
life, for sure.
But in terms of sort of material kinds of
metrics, bigger is better.
Speaker 1: In the book, a fascinating example
of this that you give is you compare, for
example, a very, very small animal like a
mouse to an elephant and you say, well, the
elephant lives a lot longer in terms of time.
The elephant also has a much slower heartbeat.
And so over the course of the life of a mouse
and an elephant, even though the elephant
is here for many more years, it's heart beats
more slowly.
And both the mouse and the elephant would
have roughly the same number of heartbeats
per lifetime.
That that's quite fascinating.
What what is the underlying principle that
is guiding that?
Speaker 3: Yes.
No, it's it's it is.
It's quite fascinating that the number of
heartbeats and a lifespan if you look across
all mammals from the smallest to the largest
is roughly the same, about one and a half
billion.
And what is underlying that and all of the
scaling laws is networks is the fact that
all these things are controlled by networks.
And all the work that I did was in terms of
deriving the matter, the concepts and the
mathematics that show you where these scaling
laws come from and in particular, where this
scaling law, this invariant, so to speak,
this this constancy of heartbeats comes from.
And indeed, just let me just go back to something
I said earlier, just to give you a sense of
that is that the I said that the bigger you
are, the the less energy needed personnel
to stay alive.
So your your cells are working less hard than
your cats or dogs, but they're working harder
than your elephants, so to speak.
And so the bigger you are, the less hard the
cells work.
Therefore, less damage is done within the
cell and in transporting energy and information
through these networks.
Therefore, you can live longer because you're
doing less damage.
So that's sort of the the the the the sort
of simple idea behind it.
You live longer if you're bigger because you
do less damage transporting energy information
and resources to the cells to keep you alive.
And so that causes the decrease and the and
in effect, all rates basically slow down the
bigger you are in a systematic way.
So that if you look through the right lens,
it's not just that a life spot lifespans are
the same, so to speak.
That is, you measure them by heartbeats, but
your growth rates and everything else is sort
of the same if you they all rescale to look
quite similar, if you rescale accordingly.
So it brings up sort of a speculative question.
Even though a mouse lives two years and well,
is one hundred and twenty five years, maybe
in a certain sense, experientially.
It's the same with great distances have re
scaled appropriately.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
This is often brought up when people talk
about their dogs, quite frankly, where they
say we experience the dog's life as being
relatively short compared to ours.
But if we account for all of these systems
you're talking about, the dog may experience
a life that too.
It feels just as long as ours.
We just don't know.
Speaker 3: We don't know.
Of course, as I say, it's speculative.
Yeah, by the way, I want to add one major
caveat to that.
Yeah, we are one of those mammals.
And indeed, if you look at us as sort of biologically,
biologically meaning, when we were hunter-gatherers
before we discovered language, social networks,
innovation and creature, all the marvelous
things that we do now, when we look purely
biologically, we fit perfectly on all these
scaling cards.
We have the right metabolic rate.
We lived 30 or 40 years now.
Some of your listeners may have already realized
that one and a half billion heartbeats corresponds
to a human being two about 30 or 40 years,
which of course, was the lifespan of human
beings on the average until maybe only 100
hundred years ago.
You know, my great great grandfather is life
expectancy was about forty five, and that
was typical in I come from England and the
United Kingdom, but it's also typical in the
United States.
So then we violated that.
So we completely violated the scaling law
in terms of our metabolism.
We now, even though biologically we only use
2000 calories a day.
But in fact, the amount of energy we need
to have this kind of standard and quality
of life is more like 100 times that.
So all of our metrics get distorted and we've
separated ourselves from this marvelous unity
and integration of nature.
Speaker 1: Let's let's dig into exactly that
topic because there's so many different aspects
of what you talk about that are relevant to
this idea of human longevity.
First, I guess, to kind of establish a level
playing field, is it not true that even when
the average life expectancy at birth was 40
or 45, that that was significantly influenced
by high infant mortality and that if one made
it to say age 20, their odds of becoming much
older were actually quite similar to what
they are today.
Is that not a factor?
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's partly true.
It's still nevertheless true that so let me
give you some statistics.
In about 18 1830, the lifespan of a human
being on the planet was about 35.
Maybe.
And what became developed countries, that
number was more like 45 40 early 40s.
But it increased.
If you took out infant mortality, just remove
those that died before age one, because in
the natural state, you know, we're supposed
to have, you know, 10 to 12 children and three
or four supposed to die.
They put it sort of crassly and and so if
you take out those that died in infancy and
the number does increase to 40, 45 and then.
But then just as you say, if you make it beyond,
I forget the age, exactly.
But if you make it sort of age 10, 12 and
so on into through your teens, your likelihood
of reaching 60 is now not as high as it is
now, that's for sure, but is already significantly
increased and indeed, people did live in the
world.
We obviously know historically people who
live to 60, 80, even 100, obviously, but they
were outliers and a long tail in the distribution
of ages.
So and the the biggest change, by the way,
that took place in increasing longevity took
place in the 19th century with the introduction
of access to clean water, right hand hygiene,
hygiene and sewer putting in sewers and so
on had has had the biggest increase in our
longevity because up to then, the overwhelming
majority of people did not wash themselves,
obviously didn't have access to hygiene.
Speaker 1: We're going to pause our interview
with Professor Geoffrey West.
There we will post
the full interview to
our YouTube channel.
Don't miss it.
Absolutely.
Fascinating.
The YouTube channel, of course, youtube.com
slash The David Pakman Show.
Y